poland has received more refugees from
ukraine than any other country while
moscow has warned its government to stay
out of the war but is there a risk of a
spillover and if so what would be the
fallout this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
hasam seeker russia's invasion of
ukraine has had a direct impact on
neighboring countries most of whom are
members of nato poland has become vital
in the western effort to defend ukraine
with some of the fighting getting close
to its border last week russian forces
targeted the western ukrainian city of
lev near the polish border just as the
u.s president was visiting poland and
according to ukraine's military three
weeks after the war began a russian
drone flew over poland before entering
ukrainian airspace where it was shot
down the situation has forced nato to
decide on how to respond to incidents
like this inside the borders of its
member states u.s president joe biden
visited ukrainian refugees and nato
troops in the polish capital warsaw on
saturday during a speech to a large
crowd he warned russia against violating
nato territory don't even think
about
moving on one single inch of nato
territory
we have sacred obligation
we have a sacred obligation under
article 5 to defend each and every inch
of nato territory
poland has had an important role since
the conflict began last month it went
from rejecting migrants from the middle
east to opening its doors to those from
ukraine hosting more than 2 million
people the largest group of ukrainian
refugees in europe poland hosts nato
battle groups to deter russia and
reinforce other members when needed
and along with romania it's also a
gateway for nato arms supplies heading
to ukraine
hundreds of stinger missiles javelin
anti-tank weapons and other munitions
have passed through its borders
well let's bring in our guests now to
talk more about this in warsaw ray
wojciech he is a
senior fellow at the center for european
policy analysis and a former military
attache at the u.s embassy in warsaw in
brussels robert shell a senior fellow at
the casimir pulaski foundation in poland
and a former polish diplomat and nato
official and joining us from oxford in
england samuel romney an associate
fellow at the royal united services
institute good to have you all with us
so um ray watching if i could start with
you since you are in uh warsaw um what's
the mood in the country right now with
the the
significant role that poland now finds
itself in here
well uh to start off with uh
in general the polish uh population has
done a remarkable job in the government
in hosting uh literally now millions so
we're seeing more uh people uh
migrating or refugees falling into
poland than we've seen refugee flows in
this short span of time uh since world
war ii i think it's an important point
to highlight
you mentioned the migrants on the
belarus border this is all part of the
full operation that putin initiated last
summer that
hybrid warfare attack against the polish
border those were migrants being used as
weapons against pullman destabilizing
the border and then also tying up the
military force uh so that they can't
concentrate and focus on their primary
mission but overall generally uh the
polls are very positive about what
they're able to do to help their
ukrainian brothers they see this
existential crisis for them for ukraine
as an existential crisis for poland
should they lose
and uh robert shell um how do you see
poland's role uh in all of this
particularly
uh when you remember that before this
conflict um started poland has had the
reputation of being kind of the bad boys
of europe um up till then with a lot of
criticism um about their moves that in
inside poland that were seen as
trampling on the judiciary on
independent media and and and sliding
backsliding over democratic norms and
yet now it is a very important player in
all of this
well i mean you know there are of course
nobody is perfect and there are various
issues which which i'm frankly indeed as
you mentioned to do with a
dispute that the polish government has
had for instance with you know uh new
institutions but you know and poland has
unpolished the phrase actually spending
more time
also can confirm that you know polish
political scene is quite polarized but
having said all this
there is a a very strong degree of unity
on this issue it is really bipartisan
there is not that much you know
difference frankly if there's debate
you know it's it's about if you like the
tactics it's about the the details of
response but you know uh poland knows
uh the the threat and poland has been
among those countries who have been
providing
you know
a very realistic analysis of the
situation
it has not always been heard
sufficiently um you know strongly so to
speak in in uh other in international
institutions
so but it's not about being vindicated
vindicated by by the analysis the key
issue is like you mentioned at the
beginning
poland is actually the key country in
terms of both uh indeed uh handling of
the of the refugee which is you know
crisis which i think you know polls have
really rushed to help the ukrainians and
so that's one miscalculation of putin
but also poland indeed is is the
frontline state and it's uh not only
hosting
uh you know allied troops uh now it's
about ten thousand allied troops
predominantly american but not only uh
and and providing of course the vital
essentially hub facility for
for the essential you know defense uh
assistance to ukraine but actually uh
poland is also doing a lot when it comes
to you know
increasing for example defense
expenditure uh you know enacting the
necessary legislation so in other words
poland is is you know taking not only
this crisis very seriously but it's it's
responding so
you know uh in in a way which which
frankly you know would be good if he was
copied by
by more countries between western europe
so uh
that is perhaps one of the key reasons
why president biden came straight from
brussels meeting of nato eu and g7 to to
to call it not only to also but also to
meet uh u.s troops in jesus
uh samuel romney um if we could talk
about the the security aspect of this
and we mentioned at the top there the
risk of a spillover if this
uh
escalates into something beyond
ukraine's uh borders if that does happen
poland is likely to be very much in the
eye of that storm
well i think that there's certainly a
grave risk of an accidental uh
escalation that drags poland
into a broader sense of conflict because
even though russia claims that has
pivoted its military operation towards
focusing on the liberation of donbass as
it calls it so moving towards eastern
ukraine we've seen a continuation of
strikes in western ukraine strikes on
oil depots communications towers
s300
air defense systems
factory and munitions factories inside
leve and even as well as lutsk
and one of those strikes recently hit
between 10 kilometers is the polish
border so it's not inconceivable there
could be an accidental strike that
brings poland into it they've already
had an errant missile strike that hit a
turkish ship on the first day of the war
so that kind of accident is possible in
terms of a deliberate russian attack on
poland i think that that's quite remote
i think in terms of risk the countries
that are most at risk are the neutral
post-soviet states georgia and moldova
probably followed by uh estonia
lithuania and bosnia because the
russians have threatened there and then
poland being further removed from that
uh ray wojcik um one thing you notice
about about poland's approach to all of
this as well in contrast with with some
of its european and nato partners is
that they've taken much more of a
hard-line approach to russia than some
of their allies they've wanted more
forceful sanctions they've wanted um
more in terms of of defensive assistance
to to the ukrainian forces but uh
they've been they've been overruled on
that up to now what do you make of that
well i mean that's just part and parcel
of polish history there's a long uh
problematic history in this region and
the what the russians did here uh
colluding with the germans in world war
ii what the russians did by occupying
poland for 123 years those things those
are long memories and the polls never
ever even with the nato russian founding
act in 1997 uh fully bought into the
idea that russia would become a fortune
democracy and as robert pointed out
those threat assessments that the polls
uh baltic states and romanians for
example were uh pushing uh and called uh
russophobic uh by many have been born
out to uh to be true so in the case of
uh a polish uh uh focus on
uh defense uh preparedness as robert
pointed out not only is three percent
defense spending uh being uh is also
announced but as far as nato uh gdp
spending that puts poland at number two
the united states is the only other ally
that will be spending more on defense
owen has pledged to increase their
military size from approximately 140 000
territorial and active today
to almost doubling or more 300 uh
thousand uh troops uh total when you at
the end of the day and then poland is uh
focused on a big monetization program
that predates uh this latest attack the
ultravery sanguine uh from uh even
before 2008 when the russians invaded
georgia so the polls take this very
seriously and they're very disappointed
all these years that the west europeans
mostly have a different view a good part
uh if there could be said any good part
is the west europeans are waking up that
see the germans talking about their
defense spending changes modernizing
their military and being a more willing
and able uh facilitator of defense on
nato's eastern flank so those are all
good things uh but it's coming at a very
late date and and same thing for u.s uh
supplying of uh weapons
to uh ukraine now as far as the big
initiatives the three that the bulge
have really pushed and unfortunately
have not occurred one is the mig-29
transfer very disappointing how that
worked out uh from poland to ukraine the
second is uh the no-fly zone bolton is a
big supporter of that and then also a
ground mission on one of nato at least
considered a way to protect humanitarian
quarters with the ground up he's keeping
probably more like a peacemaking mission
so all those are strong initiatives
supporting ukraine uh hopefully they'll
pick up momentum
robert shell uh what do you make of the
the relationship between
the eu as a whole and poland right now
given that they become a kind of an
indispensable partner uh in all of this
um
will this newfound favor uh kind of
embolden the government in warsaw now
well you know politics never stops
obviously so there are some issues but i
think they kind of you know hopefully
they sort of park to be dealt separately
the important thing is you know is that
in poland there is a you know
you know a very very strong support to
the european union i mean you know i
think only nato probably
you know gathers gathers higher higher
figures when it comes to opinion polls
uh
but it's it's fair to say that you know
eu as an institution has traveled a long
road as well i mean there's been a lot
of um
a lot of action not just you know talk
as it used to be the case you know the
famous you know expressing concerns etc
uh eu is uh really a key player when it
comes to sanctions and you know at the
moment i would say
the new institutions have really been uh
been
been quite exemplary in terms of you
know pushing forward the problem as
always is that of course you need all
the capitals to line up and at the
moment poland is is very strongly he's
not alone of course but you know arguing
for uh going for where it really hurts
the kremlin regime which is essentially
the gas
and oil experts that is again you see
poland well has done a bit more homework
i mean the the the the gist of it is
that by the end you know by the end of
the sea poor poland will be totally
independent of russian gas because it's
taken steps to actually invest
in for instance liquefied gas and things
of the nature alternative rules so of
course some other countries in in europe
are slightly less prepared but
nevertheless i think that there is a
gathering of momentum and it's also you
know
you know a certain kind of
political example uh i would just
mention the fact that no matter i know
there's been some
critical or even some sniping remarks
from uh from the sidelines but the
ukrainians appreciated the fact that
poland's took elite actually in having
you know three prime ministers from
polanche and slovenia uh traveling to
kiev and meet with uh
you know with president zielinski which
was you know the only visit of that
level uh to happen so i think you know
poland is kind of showing the way but
yes i mean some issues related to uh
what you mentioned that the question of
the
you know the judicial system they they
will need to be kind of you know
discussed further but at the moment the
important thing is that there is unity
among organizations and there is a
determination to actually press ahead
and impose
such high costs on on the on the regime
in russia that it will reconsider what
it's doing right now but of course you
know one needs to support the ukrainians
in their fight and that's also something
that also is is is very strongly our
being for so yes i mean it's uh
you know the crisis brings out the best
one could say in in in those uh who who
care about security and
and support for those victims of
aggression
let's pick on pick up on some of that
with uh samuel romney and i want to ask
you um at some stage uh when ukraine is
no longer dominating the headlines if
there's a negotiated peace or the war
becomes
uh one of one of attrition and just
falls out of the spotlight the the
underlying issues
uh
the the rule of law dispute with poland
with the eu are not going to go away are
they i mean those issues are are going
to have to be addressed
well certainly i mean i think that uh
poland has certainly uh used and
leveraged this crisis to be a vanguard
in terms of dealing with uh with russia
and that's been a very positive thing i
mean poland has been able to actually
steer and influence eu policy in the
direction of uh energy because it was
one of the most dependent countries on
uh coal coming from russia up to 70
percent and uh it was made an early ban
on that and that helped
steer more european conditions towards
at least discussing the uh energy
embargo we've seen poland take the lead
on uh on a variety of other issues from
peacekeeping to arms transfers so that
leadership that role of poland is both a
leader and an outlier is quite
interesting i think it's something that
will kind of continue to persist even
after this crisis because the rule of
law issues won't be going away
ray watching what do you what do you
make of that uh dynamic there's a kind
of a push and pull
uh
thing going on here between poland uh
and its dealings with with other
european partners
yeah i would say two things on this
point one is if you try to uh understand
uh the
the position
of the current government of poland
there's two sides of the story so the
government of poland
sees um
reformation or their reforms uh in the
court system previously uh they tried to
do some things with the media and so
forth uh in other areas um they see that
is their domain uh to deal with so part
of the argument with the eu
and also by extension the united states
is these are things uh that are uh
domestic issues that we want to change
or or uh or things that were not
reformed during the economy's time we
want to reform them so i think there's
two sides of the story it's not all
about uh
what you read in the west in my view
that poland is somehow an autocratic or
almost an autocratic state which i think
totally overblows uh what the reality is
on the ground here so uh so that's one
the other is uh the u.s ambassador
relatively new sonos vietnam virginia
mark oginski has made it clear over and
over uh in washington and then here
since he's arrived that uh even though
uh those issues are issues he wants to
work on
and uh uh deal with with the polls uh
nothing there's gonna be no daylight in
between on security defense issues and
what's the mission at hand right now so
those issues are not going to play a
role or a primary role in any of the
discussions going on with the united
states and in effect if anything things
are speeding up on security defense as
far as weapons transfers to poland and
then transfers from poland to ukraine
robert shell what do you see as the main
security issues for poland in this in
this going forward in terms of its uh
defensive uh readiness should should
this conflict escalate
well i mean first of all one needs to
keep once cool so you know we we cannot
basically allow ourselves to be
kind of intimidated by uh you know
you know
relatively skillful although by now i
think
you know the methods are known everybody
you know narrative of the kremlin
because that's that's basically what
they're trying to do and you know we've
seen some direct uh you know verbal
disinformation attacks on
poland some sort of article by the
former president of medvedev now the
polls are not easily scared so i think
you know we you know we'll we'll keep
the call but of course there are various
issues related to the way that russia is
conducting this war in ukraine which is
not really winning then ukrainians have
proven to be in an open battle much more
successful in the russian army i mean
the myth of the russian army as
successful and efficient is gone but
having said this russia has shown itself
to be once again uh be totally
unconcerned about you know human life
the use of of totally disreported force
and and basically you know attack on on
the civilians
so that is something which you know the
poles and and other nato made
members have to take very seriously
hence there'll be i think more uh stress
on the kind of you know protection
against missiles and so on and any
attack obviously in russia or nato
countries would be suicidal for russia
but you know we don't want to see even
one inch of for instance college
territory to be uh destroyed by by by
the madmen in the kremlin so i think
there is not well concerned that there
is a word going on right now to
configure nato to be even more uh
you know directly uh kind of
protecting the the defensive lines of
not just poland but the baltic states
and also helping other countries uh that
were mentioned in the region such as for
instance you know uh georgia uh also
even the balkans who knows you know uh
so it's uh it's a kind of
multi-multi-faceted effort but you know
it just shows that the anniversary of
nato membership which we kind of
celebrated recently uh has been one of
the you know this you know joining nato
has been one of the best thing that
happened uh to poland because it's a
completely different bowl game when you
are you know uh together with other 29
allies and we know that we will we will
win but you have to be prepared for the
unexpected because that's the kind of
models operandi of of the of the russian
of the kremlin regime
samuel romney how do you see poland's
role in this the longer this goes on
well i see poland playing an
increasingly decisive role both in terms
of bringing european countries together
by trilateral frameworks i think the
polish czech republic slovenian
framework which has already produced a
10-point plan is one positive step
another is obviously the british polish
ukrainian platform that's also been
created that's another positive step and
given the fact that poland and britain
are both vital uh contributors to army
ukraine britain with the movement of
laws and other anti-tank weapons
especially and training poland acting
using his borders as a conduit for it
those trilateral frameworks will be very
important for polish uh influence going
forward in terms of policies that
portland will be bringing forward there
are several that i think that they'll be
really trying to advance with particular
vigor
one will probably be cutting the
russian banks off the remaining ones off
from swift and there's already support
for that inside the united states we're
seeing jim risch for example talking
about secondary sanctions on russian
banks u.s poland cooperation and the
financial punishment of russia is
something we should watch for poland
might also be pushing for uh switzerland
and any european countries that are on
the fence about banning rt and sputnik
to make that kind of step as well as
granting russians who are defecting and
dissidence asylum particularly those
from the military
and uh pushing towards more
comprehensive and sweeping sanctions on
individual russians like the two million
russians who are supportive of the
united russia party and some other
ventures like that could be things that
poland will be lobbying for you to do so
play a very active role in the sanctions
regime and also in the coordination of
military assistance to ukraine moving
forward
all right wojciech if i could turn back
to you on this on what's probably going
to be the last word there's been talk
for several years of permanently
assigning u.s and nato forces
more to poland
do you think that's a real possibility
now
yes i do and i think the interesting
point about that
is in the last couple years just like
the threat assessment where the polls
had been maligned a little bit by some
in the west uh russophobic what do you
let's we can get along uh the polls were
always uh
clear-eyed about this and then when the
polls proposed this uh
permanent basing of american forces
specifically and or nato forces on the
eastern flank uh the joke uh came out
about for trump and it was going to be
and everybody focused uh and made a
laughing point about fort trump well the
bottom line is it was a great initiative
poland drew up two different papers
about it signed an agreement with the
united states on a lot of new
initiatives not a permanent base yet but
we're getting
much closer because poland laid that
groundwork and i think the u.s and nato
you hear secretary uh stoltenberg
intimating this every day now uh is much
closer to considering permanent facing
u.s forces and other allies all along
the eastern flank i think it will become
a reality all right on that we are going
to have to leave it thanks very much to
all three of you ray wojcik robert shell
and samuel romney thanks very much for
being on inside story and thank you as
always for watching remember you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeela.com and for
further discussion you can go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
has some seeker and the whole team here
in doha bye for now